Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie gorilla city.
We got a break this down it's going to be
so awesome the flash A-Team is going to earth
2 to fight gorilla city, the B team is going
to be left on earth one to take care of another
metahuman that's kind of what they did last
year so there's a new round of the flash ring
giveaway.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video and I have
a couple of updates about the video schedule
for the next couple of videos at the end of
this oh my God this is gonna be so amazing
so they're teasing flash versus Grodd part
of team flash goes to earth 2 the reason for
this like the reason they take the people
they do is because Tom Felton is like the
new special guest star the season of course
are going to take him Caitlin has a special
connection to Grodd she's the one that he
really likes.
Obviously you get to take the flash and Cisco
is the next new superpower person was a little
bit better with his abilities and say Wally
who's actually needed back in Central city
so Jesse quick Wally West team up in the be
fun to see what she's learned in the time
that we haven't seen or maybe she can show
Wally a couple new tricks, so a lot of you
been commenting about why they been paying
so much attention Wally's character like you
think the gonna kill off Barry and it will
be Wally show they just want to have like
really cool episodes where Wally can be the
flash of earth one, while the main flash is
off doing things like this in gorilla city
for 2 hours the whole pitch just turns your
head upside down when you read the synopsis
for the episode because in the comics gorilla
Grodd is one of flashes biggest enemies, but
what the TV show is done is sort of aligned
him with team flash for now that might change
the future but here already the synopsis attack
on gorilla city Barry and team traveled to
gorilla city on earth 2 in face Grodd when
Jesse quick informed the team that her father
has been abducted Barry Caitlin Cisco and
Julian voyage to earth 2 on a rescue mission
to save Harry from gorilla city as they trekked
through the forest Barry and the team are
immediately captured and brought to Grodd
Grodd tells them, he needs their help to stop
Solovar the leader of gorilla city as Solovar
wants to invade Earth one.
Meanwhile back on earth one Jesse and kid
flash team up hit the streets to stop a metahuman
that can control gravity with HR and Joe guiding
them from star labs so the big thing about
this is that were gonna meet Solovar obviously
gorilla city is huge.
It's a 2-part episode, and it doesn't start
for 2 weeks.
So it's on break next week I'll be doing bonus
videos, but after that they'll be a run of
episodes I don't know if they'll be another
break before the end of the season but is
what you guys really pumped up.
If you're big Rick and Morty fan Keith David
who's done a bunch of voices on that show
he's done a lot of stuff.
He's a very identifiable voice is going to
be doing the voice or Solovar is even real
my the only real person.
Maybe.
Or maybe, just maybe were all real.
You know me I'm reverse derive a short neck
and legs.
I went to college with camera.
I saved goes to the does life in Vietnam and
Beth how many times have I been a shoulder
for you to Cry on too many okay so maybe which
is all.
So this is a whole lot of stuff that I just
dropped and that synopsis let's pick through
it one is the fact that Solovar is actually
the bad gorilla in this equation.
Normally gorilla Grodd is evil.
Solovar is the good eight that's the way it
started out in the comics what they might
be doing is if this is straight up in the
not misleading us there's not some big twist
with Grodd was trying to mislead them that
they're just aligning Grodd with team flash
and he won't be there enemy or the second
option is is that they're trying to be a little
misleading and what Grodd is doing is he is
just misleading team flash, to trick them
into helping him take over gorilla city, so
that he will be the leader of their society
because the footage doesn't tell you whole
lot here, but when you read Solovar's Backstory,
it sounds like there's going to be some big
twist this episode for many years.
Solovar is the leader of gorilla city a hidden
city of hyper intelligent gorillas renowned
for his wisdom and psychic powers he is virtually
unchallenged except by the villainous gorilla
Grodd rivalry is so great that after Solovar
is captured by humans Grodd falls into Central
city to learn the secrets of.
Solovar's mind control powers he succeeds
in this but the flash captures him after Solovar
escapes and tells the flash of Grodd.
So just assuming that there is no twist in
the synopsis is correct.
This is the other way around.
Solovar is the evil one and Grodd is the good
one which just blew my mind when I read it
I actually thought that it was wrong like
somebody wrote this synopsis wrong gorilla
Grodd supposed to be the evil a so borrowing
from Cisco's donkey Kong joke flash versus
super intelligent gorilla best worst videogame
ever Grodd get soaked through the warp pipe
into gorilla city in they already have an
established culture of hyper intelligent apes
that Solovar is leading and he sort of the
odd man out.
So if you haven't seen that episode in a little
while or you don't remember Grodd's relationship
with team flash Caitlin always tried to help
him with the way they left it was kind of
ambiguous like Grodd should be pissed that
they sent him to gorilla city with the way
Harrison wells talked about it.
It's a good place so the probably have some
fun when the flash meets Grodd again for the
first time.
Like all yeah.
Remember the last time we saw each other that
you trick me and punch me to that super Mario
warp pipe to earth 2 so will just see how
they play It when the episode drops, but remember
one of the things on the future board that
they're trying to change is a giant gorilla
attack on earth one, the news headline said
city still recovering from gorilla attack.
So there was this terrible gorilla attack
destroyed most of the city, so if they don't
change things in Solovar gets his way or it
secretly Grodd is trying to control them gorilla
city leaves an assault on Central city just
destroys almost everything so I'm so excited
about this.
Maybe I'll do a gorilla Grodd bonus video
next week because he is really cool history
on the show it's a little bit different from
the comics because of that break leave all
your requests for bonus videos in the comments
below.
There's so many things that are going on right
now.
I'm so excited this is going to be a lot of
fun and what's can happen with the video schedule
today is because they dropped a new iron fist
trailer went to do my legends of tomorrow
video.
Next, then I'll do iron fist instead of doing
arrow and because a Legion is starting tonight
what's can happen on Thursday is I'll do my
Legion video first then I'll do my arrow video.
So after that I'll figure the video schedule
out but for the next couple of videos it's
gonna be legends of tomorrow and more iron
fist footage then Legion then Arrow, so there's
a whole bunch of stuff coming I'll try to
get to it as fast as possible but if there
any video request that you guys have just
leave them in the comments below.
Congratulations to the new flash ring giveaway
winner Josh OP please private message me on
the back and my channel so I can get your
contact details.
There was a new round that started in this
video I'll remind everyone when I post legends
of tomorrow in a couple hours while you wait
for that you can click here for the flash
episode and you can click here to rewatch
the iron fist trailer thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you guys
next video!